Welcome to this course
on Android design.
I'm Nick, a Design Advocate at Google.
>> And I'm James,
a course developer at Udacity.
>> And I'm Roman,
also a Design Advocate at Google.
>> If you haven't
figured it out already,
this is a course on Android design.
>> With over a million apps
in the Google Play Store,
design is an important element
to making your apps stand out.
>> Right.
And unlike the early days of Android, it
isn't enough just to have a good idea,
and to implement it.
Your users will expect, nay,
demand something that's easy to use and
beautiful.
>> In this lesson,
we will start with a quick overview
of Android design principles.
In the rest of the course we'll explore
key Android design principles through
the lens of material design,
the new visual language in Android 5.0.
Let's get started.